an emergency service that's struggling
to serve in emergencies growing with
England's Hospital waiting lists are the
stories of people who've called for an
ambulance and waited hours like Mary
Jane Lani whose 87 year old mum fell one
evening and hit her head study arrived
at quarter to eight the following
morning
um so I think that's the total of ten
and a half hours he waited for the
ambulance then there were another 10
hours inside the ambulance outside the
hospital
I believe the hospital the a e
department is so pushed that they're
used in the ambulances the back of the
ambulances stretches as an extra Ward as
well as individual stories like Mary
Janes there are stories told by data so
here's a stamp for you if I had fallen
ill or got injured in England in
November and taken myself off to
accident and emergency there's a strong
chance I would have been one of nearly
40 000 people that had to wait more than
12 hours to be admitted to a hospital
department now that is a 355 increase on
the same figure from the previous
November
according to the Royal College of
emergency medicine delays like this are
costing 300 to 500 lives every week the
causes hinge points and blockages two
full Wards and staff shortages we also
recognize the big pressure that we're
seeing played through in terms of
ambulance Handover delays is largely
triggered by those who are fit to leave
hospital but delayed in doing so we need
to free up that big capacity but ask
pretty much anyone involved with the NHS
why this much cherished National
Institution is so critically ill and
they'll tell you this what we're seeing
is the result of 10 years of of
underfunding understaffing and under
resourcing the NHS what the pandemic has
done is it's aggravated the situation
the system insiders say is now brittle
and unable to flex with the seasons or
surprises many many Winters have been
challenging but what we've seen this
year is that the usual level of winter
pressure that we might see would usually
Abate in the summer you'd get a bit of a
respite you'd be able to do more work
and then the winter pressures would come
again but this year it became so
pressured that the whole summer felt
like winter level pressures so then when
we got to Winter we were already at a
much higher Baseline of pressure
when will the NHS get better will it get
better the doctor's prognosis is gloomy
not for many months and not without
serious financial help Rory challenge Al
Jazeera London